for more on all this and the remaining
mexico ruling let's bring in texas
congressman chip roy he's also a member
of the house judiciary committee and a
former federal prosecutor sir thank you
very much for joining us obviously we
want to get your reaction to the supreme
court siding with the president
over this uh remain in mexico policy
adopted under the trump administration
shannon bringing up there the very clear
and present risks that that brings to
the border those making the dangerous
journey to get to the border and
obviously to the american people as this
crisis grows your reaction
well first of all uh justices alito
thomas and gorsuch had it exactly right
in terms of what we're actually facing
and what the law is right the law of the
united states is that we ought to secure
the border we have to have opera
operational control of the border and
you must detain those individuals who
are being adjudicated for say an asylum
claim that is not happening that's what
the american people need to understand
the administration is refusing to do
that and that is at the heart of the
descent's position unfortunately the
majority majority pursued another sort
of technical ruling the same chief
justice that made attacks out of thin
air for obamacare says oh we're going to
read this really technically to say that
the administration can continue to avoid
their actual statutory responsibility to
secure the border that's what happened
today now that was predictable so i
introduced legislation in the spring
h.r 7772 to ensure that we actually turn
away i think we ought to make crystal
clear that we turn away at the border i
believe the law says that now but it was
predictable that the court would side
with the administration to interpret it
to be able to have the discretion to be
able to not turn away at the border and
it's crippling our country and now you
have 53 dead migrants sadly 53 dead
migrants in the back of a tractor
trailer a man who just got mowed down on
a highway we have the four that were
dead in a jeep this morning and all
that's in brooks county where the
sheriff there has a mobile morgue for
the bodies of the migrants when are we
going to stop pretending this is
compassionate it's not and the court got
it wrong congressman do you have any
update by the way on that uh situation
for us obviously
with four people now facing charges
we're learning more about this alleged
driver posing as a victim can you add
any further detail at this hour
well the one thing i can say for sure i
mean obviously the numbers are now i
think 53. uh when i talk to border
patrol and i talk them almost daily i'm
going to go back to the border next week
the fact is they are distracted and
they're unable to do the processing at
our ports of entry to be able to stop
this like if they could stop it you know
right when it's happening then you don't
have them riding in the heat all the way
from the border to san antonio they we
need to allow them to do their job and
they're they're literally upset about it
right because they could do their job if
we allowed them but instead we allow the
cop the cartels to have control of the
border fentanyl pour in they get bum
rushed and then they can't actually run
the scanners they can't do all the work
they can't process this to make good
determinations and stop it before it
happens i do not understand how they can
view this as compassionate to allow open
borders to allow people to die
it's just
the wrong thing for our country to do
the governor there greg abbott gave a
press conference about this time
yesterday
over to those 53 dead migrants in that
semi-tractor trailer
the vice president of the united states
kamala harris
seeing the blame placed on the
administration then responded here's
greg abbott and kamala harris listen
because of
the way the dubai administration is not
enforcing the immigration laws
it's attracting people and enticing
people to make this very dangerous track
his response with her 50 dead bodies in
his state is to go straight to politics
instead of dealing with the realities of
the issue
hard to imagine uh the kamala here is
calling out greg abbott for not dealing
with the realities of the issue when he
and
citizens of his state are living through
this every single day as you well know
congressman
so where is the blame and
what is this war of words at the state
level in the federal level over what is
happening at our southern border
well the vice president sure as hell
couldn't find yavaldi on a map until she
wanted to politicize the deaths of the
young in yevaldi let's just be clear
about that the president sure as hell
didn't know where yevaldi was and they
still haven't come down to the border
kamala harris makes a blow-by trip to el
paso and route to a fundraiser in
california and then has the nerve to say
that the governor's playing politics
when we have migrants dying on our
ranches in our property when we've got
to deal with the consequences of
fentanyl pouring into our schools we
know exactly what's going on and texas
is going to have to start taking action
because the federal government refuses
to do it it's our communities our state
our families we're under assault every
single day with cartels being empowered
and we don't want to sit by while
migrants are dying while democrats say
oh open borders are good for migrants
and good for america it's not true and
we're seeing the consequences of that in
real time and that's what's actually
happening currently all right
congressman chip roy really appreciate
your time this afternoon thank you sir
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now